i have a story about this in college my
friend
this is my friend though actually so
this is probably one of the craziest
things i've ever done i'm i'm going to
own it so
i'm going to say it on camera so this my
friends have a little bit of crazy my my
friend was dating this guy went to a
different school and this guy i i think
i've told you this story before i knew
he was cheating on her because he
cheated on the last girl all the time
and i told her i was like look
you can date him if you want i wouldn't
he was kind of a [ __ ] like he always
slid into my dms when he had like this
other no because he used to but i would
i would never like entertain it because
i was like i wasn't special he entered
it was like a copy yeah he was just
doing any go
yeah yeah
yeah yeah but anyway so he leaves our
school and he goes to a different school
right and so i don't know why like her
friend was like determined to catch this
man cheating
and i was just like bored this day i'm
gonna be honest i had nothing to do i
was like oh this sounds fun
no volleyball ended you know how it is
when volleyball ends you just got a lot
of free time i was like i got you that
was a drought a little bit
so she comes over and we're like she's
like i'm tired of kaylin like like he
was being crazy towards her just named
him i don't care did you do that well
they broke up now sorry caleb
anyways anyways so well we decided we
were like okay he goes to a small school
let's look at the girls on the rosters
at the other school that looked like her
so she kind of she kind of looked like
cheska a little bit like to be honest
like
no no no no like she kind of like if why
does she have the same aggression as
chess girl
oh no no
no no but anyway she looked like jessica
so i was like let me find the girls
because it was like a small like like
white school so like obviously there's
only going to be a couple black girls
yeah so we would just like dm the black
girls and be like yo do you know kaelin
like is he has he dm'd you and like
literally within like
i probably did this for 20 minutes it
didn't even take up an afternoon i was
kind of irritated so literally you went
to see all the black girls and we're
like yeah you know this guy do you know
this guy yeah
yeah because girls will do that like
they'll d i mean like they'll
like we'll dm each other
sorry go on well i mean at that point i
had a lot of time
about cheating
you don't even understand like
i'd like to complete tasks yeah so then
i do not condone any of this behavior i
get i get that i don't care
i can donate no i know i'm just thinking
i'm saying this with a guy and i'd do it
again like
so actually no this one i wouldn't have
because i get the evidence i'm like
looking i get the evidence but then this
this girl ends up like going back to him
and it's awkward for me
cause then now the guy and all of his
friends at the school i'm the demon
because you don't know their
relationship and now i owned it i was
like you haven't
cheated on right and you're thinking oh
i'm gonna tell her yeah yeah the girl
he's and she goes back to him what was
the point well it doesn't matter you're
giving someone the opportunity to walk
away because you don't you know how
embarrassing the thing is you could like
paul said yeah she ended up looking like
the demon she ended up looking at the
bad boy no it depends why does it matter
what we look like to people yeah we
don't get them involved
we know our intentions whenever we do
this whether it be some people wanting
to be trifling and just wanting to end
in a relationship
others stop it stop it for me i was
bored
like i'm going